let's bring in Kurt cousins of my
Minnesota Vikings beat the Lions
yesterday still undefeated at home there
at the chargers coming up next weekend
Kirk Brown good to have you back i we
were just talking about quarterbacks
making an attack or trying to make a
tackle on an interception what is your
policy I know you've only throw 404
interceptions this year what's your
policy on that man I think first thing
you have to the second interception you
got to take off and run and show that
you're trying to cover
you can't not give effort and then
basically I just try to turn it back
inside so if they're going down the
sideline I try to get to the sideline to
bring it back to everybody else on the
team this year we had a fumble and we
had a guy returning it and one of the
big Eagles defensive lineman was lead
blocking for him and I was I was his
target and right when he got to me I
turned my back to him so he'd have to
block me in the back if he knew I was
running away from him so it was
literally like a bully on the school
playground and I knew better than to get
good whacks on him okay but if it was a
playoff game is it different well I
probably mean if I've got a 300-pound
nose tackle sprinting at me full speed I
probably go for his shins and try to
knife in and hold it I can create a car
pileup but my odds there aren't very
good but I'll I'll do everything I have
to within reason now I know you got two
little ones I think you got a
two-year-old and then your youngest was
more in March but didn't you have a
minivan
like you were practicing with the
minivan prior to needing the minivan do
you still have the minivan yeah we got
it you know minivan is probably an
insult to what it really is it's a
conversion van it's like a mini home on
wheels you know the back seat bench
folds down flat into a into a bed you
know it's got the the lights that run
through the ceiling so it's it's a fun
little deal but yeah I'm kind of an old
soul
so before being a dad I was kind of a
kind of acted like one and so I guess
I'm I'm in my natural fit now being a
dad of two boys but you bought then you
buy the van off your grandmother yep you
got it right yeah my grandma she didn't
have useful
anymore after my grandpa passed away so
I won't take off your hands you know
tailgating and things like that and uh
it's it's a 20 year old van now but back
in 2000 that was it was it was a top of
the line of course nine and for this
year's second in the NFC North you've
thrown 24 touchdowns four interceptions
do you think you'll ever satisfy your
critics and probably not I think winning
a Super Bowl you know certainly can at
the end of the day people can still
criticize it but you kind of have the
last laugh with a ring so that's really
what we're all chasing and you know
that's all that really matters in this
league and what you're measured by so
you know hopefully you know you keep
winning and in in you know stack up wins
that hopefully helps but at the end of
the day I think we've all got our
critics and they're not going anywhere
and that's okay I think honestly I play
better when when people are criticizing
me and and I think I kind of you know
come out and and and just have something
to chase and and and I think it helps
the way I play but do you take it home
and like do you talk to your wife about
it because you know there were times you
know the critics were pretty tough on
you yeah and then they will be again you
know it's pretty circle you know week to
week year to year but um you know I I do
try to stay in here and I just don't
think it helps to go looking for it
I think it'll you know keep you from
sleeping well at night and whatnot so
for my own sanity I try to stay in it's
always in front of it and just be
ignorant to it but you know inevitably
you're gonna find out something through
the media you know you're obligated to
talk to the media two three times a week
so they usually try to remind you things
before before you can stay out of it but
you know all things considered I think
there are some things I never hear about
and it honestly helps but when I do I
try to you know use it as fuel if you
will in it and you know hopefully play
better as a result
what changed this team winning seven of
its last nine games you know hard to say
I think you know we get we our offensive
coordinator offensive system changed in
the offseason and I think there's always
some growing pains with that early in
the year and I think through the first
four games we were too
and we were kind of feeling our way
through what this offense is going to
look like and I think it kind of clicked
I think we start to get a feel for you
know how we're gonna run the football
how we're going to fold the football who
we're going to lean on from a personnel
standpoint and then once we got that
feel I think offensively we've been much
stronger so you know two and two is not
the end of the world but at the time it
felt like it and then you know we've
been able to string something together
here and and you know put ourselves in a
position now where these last three
games will we'll really write the story
when we're talking to Kirk Cousins of
the Vikings quarterback when's the last
time you were watching from the
sidelines or even watching on TV a
quarterback and you go I don't know how
he does that or that's not that's
something I I don't think I could do
yeah you know there's different styles
of play and so when I watch this on
Watts and Patrick mahomes Russell Wilson
I say that's not the way that I play a
game and and it works and it's really
good and it's you know it's just not the
way I can or do play the position and
yet I watch other guys and say alright
I'm going to try to emulate that because
that's going to fit more when I'm at my
best how it should look so you know
there are plenty of guys you look at
anything that's just not that's just not
in my repertoire but you also realize
there are different ways to get it done
you know well it's like when you play
golf with somebody and they hit the ball
50 yards further than you it still
counts how many strokes to get in the
cup so it's they don't give you style
points with any of this but I still like
I think Rodgers is is actually become
underrated again for some reason I I was
watching him you know the last couple of
weeks not with San Francisco by the way
but Aaron Rodgers to me still makes it
look easier than any other quarterback
yeah I remember back in 2014 it was my
first year actually starting a few games
in a row and I was still kind of
figuring it out and struggling it you
know he was I believe you know MVP year
had been the MVP you know he's having a
great year and I remember saying to Sean
McVeigh who was my offensive coordinator
at the time saying I think we had
watched him on I football the night
before and I said I feel like when I
watched him play he knows the future
he just he knows he knows what's going
to happen before it happens you know
look on his face and the way he plays
the game and you know as I played longer
and got more experience you start to see
you know where a guy gets fed how he
develops that in the years that it takes
to get there but yeah there's no doubt
he's he's arguably the most talented
most equipped quarterback of all time
and you know we were in a bit of a
golden age you could probably say the
end of any era but you got you know Tom
Brady who they call the goat you got
Aaron Rodgers you could argue is as
talented as anybody ever and you got
young guys like practical homes they're
doing impressive things so there's
there's no shortage of good quarterbacks
around the league and there's a bunch of
names I didn't even mention well if you
look at Brees is a Hall of Famer Brady's
a Hall of Famer Ben's a Hall of Famer
Aaron Rodgers Hall of Famer Russell
Wilson is going to be a Hall of Famer
you got a gold jacket that's a lot of
guys on their way to Canton I mean that
they and also I think we're seeing this
transformation at the position that
you're seeing offensive coordinators are
head coaches adopt the college style of
the quarterback they're drafting instead
of saying hey come on in we need you to
run a Pro Set do you see that that
that's that trends going to continue
yeah I don't know I mean I'm I don't
know I that I consider myself a football
genius when it comes to the analytics
and where things are going but I think
you'll always need a guy who can operate
from the pocket can go through a
progression I think even when you look
at the quarterbacks who who people would
say oh they're they're a college offense
type quarterback the ones who are having
success can still drop that go through a
progression throw with accuracy I think
those are staples that no matter how the
offense looks you're still going to have
to do those things to be successful you
know make good decisions that whole deal
but yeah I think football will always
innovate it's a game of cat malice with
the defense that ok if you're going to
do this and how do we answer that but if
you're gonna do this to stop that how do
we expand and so it's just a constant
evolution I don't think that ever ends
me who knows maybe one day we'll go back
to running the triple option counter
like the Avengers dude you don't know so
I think that it's it's an evolving thing
year after year I'm wondering I go back
to that Big Ten title game we talk about
it a lot
you know when the Vikings played you
know
against the ATO and we couldn't help but
think when you guys Michigan stayed
Wisconsin and we went to the game and it
was just such an exciting game if I
would have said to you at the time hey
you guys are gonna be star quarterbacks
because you were what a fourth round
draft pick and Russ was a third round
draft pick Yeah right and I'm wondering
also if you've been in a first round
pick instead of a fourth round do you
think things would have played out the
same way because Brady talks about if he
was a first-round pick he might be out
of the league because the expectation
level would have been there and he
wouldn't have been ready for it yeah
100% I wasn't ready to play
you know Mike Shanahan my head coach the
time he's always been a believer in me
and he may argue that I was but at the
time I don't know that I was ready to
play it took time it took a lot of years
of reps and experience and even failing
to be able to figure it out you know I
guess if the team was patient enough
with me I'd like to think it would have
clicked but I don't think it would have
clicked in the first six games if you
know in ear one but know that no doubt
that Big Ten championship game was a lot
of fun you know Russell my action ended
up training together when the season
ended we were in the spirit IMG down in
Florida and we trained together for
about two months leading up to the
combine we were out there every day
lifting and throwing it and so I guess
hadn't worked with him you could learn
that he had all the habits and the
ability to be what he now has become so
I guess in that sense it's no surprise
but I was just turned on the Big Ten
championship game on Saturday night in
my hotel room and they said it's a ninth
annual game and we were the inaugural
one the first one I couldn't believe
it's already been nine of them so time
really flies you're getting old I'm
getting on 31 now and I think when I
first came on your show I was a junior
senior in college and was 22 23 so time
flies and these NFL years go faster
every year and the fact that we're
singing the first time you came on
[Laughter]
that's not a skill I've talked to guys
with skeletons in their closet trust me
you don't have skeletons
hey congrats on the season so far we
appreciate your time and safe travels to
Los Angeles alright thanks so much guys
you do a great job
have a great Christmas and probably see
you in the offseason Thank You Kirk
that's Kirk D cousins of the Minnesota
Vikings now maybe it's just me
kind of chopping up there were a lot of
attitude thought it was head I'll see
you in the offseason huh
because if he's still playing at the
Super Bowl and he can't be a guest
Kirk Kirk not confident in Vikings
postseason run yes but as the postseason
the offseason in the office a it could
be post Super Bowl maybe he'll come in
and visit us mMmmm I don't think so
I don't think so hmm that's headline
stuff there that's headline stuff that
is controversial a tiki cap for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]